Hey youtubers it's charlie so this is going to
be my supergirl season 2 video they're
basically from the ground up changing
the show doing Superman they're doing
Superboy Mon El doing Miss Martian
they're doing Legion of super-heroes and
they're doing Lexcorp. So  this is gonna
be a breakdown of all the crazy stuff
that's happening so let's start with the
biggest step first Superman what's going
on with him so I think Superman is going
to be butting heads with Cara because
she has this idea about how she's
supposed to be a superhero but he's been
doing he's like the gold standard and
it's going to be like okay yeah so
you're doing a couple of these things
wrong I don't totally agree with it so
it will kind of be a big brother and
that effect where he's trying to mentor
her a little bit and that like the show
is going to be doing problems that are
big enough to warrant his presence as
far as i know he's only going to be in
the first two episodes of the season
then he'll come back later on a
recurring basis so they have like a
two-hour story that they broke in half
that they're gonna tell to lead off the
season it'll be 22 episodes total i'm
expecting to see Superman like
physically see Superman in less than
half of those but one of the other big
changes in the way they tell stories
like Superman is a big part of the way
they're telling stories this season one
of the big changes from when it was on
CBS in season one is that it's going to
be heavily serialized in the vein of
the flash so like on the flash they had
like the big zoo ark that went over the
entire season they'll be things like
that happening on Supergirl season two
so they'll be like really big stories in
really small stories that only go over a
couple episodes one of the big stories
is Cadmus labs if you don't know what
Cadmus labs is think of it is like a
slightly more evil version of STAR Labs
in mercury labs on the flash so because
the flash has used the particle
accelerator explosion as a way to
surface new villains like oh you know
this big explosion goes off and creates
all these metahumans some of them are
good some of them are bad and it leads
all these crazy adventures so I think
Cadmus labs is going to be the catch-all
for them to surface really weird really
crazy stuff mostly if you haven't read a
lot of comics most people's only point
of reference for Cadmus labs is clone
Superboy what I think is going to happen
is we'll see a bunch of people from the
superman and supergirl comics come out
of cabinets lives like them
experimenting doing really crazy stuff
but here's the thing i don't think that
they're gonna do clone
Superboy I think the TV shows gonna do a
version of Superboy I just think that
it's going to be mon el because the TV
show has kind of already done a clone of
Cara and that was what bizarro was in
season one so just careful for spoilers
for Supergirl season 1 i'll explain
while they're probably not going to do
the Conner Kent that you remember from
the comics or even from Young Justice I
feel like most people's point of
reference for Conner Kent is actually
young justice but i do think that they
can do is surface cyborg superman from
Cadmus labs because during season one we
learned that Martian Manhunter was only
emulating Hank Henshaw so he's like a
good person masquerading as a really bad
person but the bat like the real bad
hank henshaw is still alive somewhere
out there he was believed to be dead but
he's still alive
I think they will resurface him as
cyborg superman eventually so in that
same vein cars adoptive father Dean Cain
is still alive and it has something to
do with Cadmus labs so you know for like
a brief period I was like wouldn't be so
amazing if Dean Cain came back as a
twisted cyborg superman like they found
some way to twist
I don't think it's going to go down that
way but I do think that Cara's father is
going to be tied to Cadmus labs this
season
Dean Cain will totally come back on the
show and some really fun plot like they
brought John Wesley Shipp back on the
flash will do the same thing with Dean
Cain so on top of that it's getting even
crazier like they're doing all the crazy
stuff that I hope that they would do
miss martian is coming on the TV show
she'll probably be involved in some sort
of secret white Martian plot if you
don't know who miss martian is from the
comics she's basically like a white
Martian that survived the destruction of
their planet who is masquerading as a
green Martian so green Martians like
Martian Manhunter equals good white
Martians equals evil so the big twist
with Miss Martian is that she's like an
evil Martian is trying to pass as a good
Martian in the Teen Titans they have
this big art but then she also tries to
go good so she's got this really
complicated psychology that makes for
really awesome TV so i'll be really fun
to see what they do with Miss Martian
this season but I almost forgot Legion
of super-heroes a lot of you saw Mon
El you're like hey wait a minute is
that going to be how they're gonna do
Legion of super-heroes is that how it's
going to work so mon el is part of the
Legion of super-heroes but there are two
him from the very very far future but
during season one we saw Superman's
Legion ring inside the fortress of
solitude so I feel like mon el will be
like a backdoor to later Legion of
super-heroes stories so get really hyped
to see some Legion easter eggs this
season but through the for my crossover
it seems like she's gonna be on a
different earth so just to be determined
in terms of merging her characters with
the characters from Earth one so let me
know in the comments do you think that
Mon el will be the TV shows version of
Superboy in what do you think is going
to crawl out of Cadmus labs the season
do you think that will see a version of
cyborg superman surface on the TV show
the big side note i almost forgot i
talked about this in previous videos so
most of you probably know about it
already but they are doing Lex Corp Lena
Luther who is the sister of lex luthor
will be on the show date today that will
be played by Morgana from Merlin so I'm
really happy about that Lex Corp now
exist like it's confirmed cannon on
Supergirl so really like Batman aside
there's almost nothing that the TV show
cannot do from the comics so it's going
to be super weird
super serialized and super intense
this season so I'm really hype about all
the changes they made it's gonna be a
lot of fun but congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner Alexander h you win a twenty-dollar amazon gift card just be
sure to private message me on the back
into my channel so you get your contact
details because it's been a couple days
since i've done Marvel my next video
will be Marvel so that should post later
tonight so get hyped so much awesome
comic book stuff going to be happening
with the TV shows this season while you
guys wait for the post you can click
here for my jason momoa Aquaman teaser
video you can click here to learn all
about the shazam movie also connected
the Justice League
so thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight